[Applause]
now back to this
chair speaking of [ __ ] men who hit
women yeah
so apparently he was abusive we got it
physically abusive
physically no they they accused of all
three so
it was well [ __ ] yeah you're gonna do
the other ones
you don't start it physical you don't go
no honestly emotionally it was great but
everything
[ __ ] give me a people's elbow every
thursday that's not how it works
i'm just saying what is i need to know
exactly what's going on here because
because it's not only fka twigs not a
sansia
yeah but sia just jumped on it and she
only claims
emotional abuse now you're gonna claim
that after
he made that video pop he made him
remember when he made that music video
six years ago i'm just saying how are
you not making your music videos pop all
of a sudden
it's emotional abuse right come on yo
oh don't tell me that's why i see always
covering her face
no
oh my god the transformer
they got child above out here
transforming them bro oh my god
no ain't it crazy shyalaboof and then
chris brown had a song called what oh my
god used to do a joke about that you
know
you know transformers is that's the
[ __ ] kardashian curse right there is
if you
anything with transformers that's a
problem damn son so really
so singer sia reveals that she was in an
abusive relationship with shia labeouf
after fka twigs came out and said the
same thing
that was the shot of the the twigs one i
i've read this in africa it was like in
a car he like
physically abused her in a car did you
look this up at all dove because you're
looking like you're searching your
memory banks and i would actually rather
you just look at it
all right let's see what that part well
there was one scene where like he
he you know he is very much like a
method actor and
she said that he said like l.a [ __ ] this
yeah this is what have you seen there's
one abuse scene
where he gets into character and said
he's never killed something so he like
starts shooting at stray dogs on the
road with her in the car
yeah something like that no one wants to
see any dogs get killed that's
an actual
[Music]
yo who shoots an innocent i don't get it
yo [ __ ] shia labeouf yo [ __ ] shia
labeouf bro yeah honestly mark wahlberg
was way
better that's true that's true i could i
was so happy not to see
la boo from the transformers i can't
believe it dude
this is disgusting any others just
shooting at straight dogs is
crazy yeah this guy's really going
through it how do you know there's
strays
yeah they could have been someone's dog
yeah just run away dogs right
you can't shoot as straight humans we
should call homeless people that
should should we call those people's
trays yeah that's just pharaoh steve
that's all that is you know feral steve
he's a rescue that's all bro but they're
not rescued
oops anyway what else we got going on
that's just that was just too crazy i
don't know the whole details
obviously you got to hear both sides you
know what i mean we need to hear what
shia got to say about all this but that
[ __ ] is a wild ass boy bro
that's crazy dog
that's you know what the problem with
being crazy is like leaning into the
crazy guy
because i don't think he was this early
in his career he was doing disney movies
even stevens bro literally like is that
a movie he was in that was the disney
channel show
he was only even he was normal right as
a kid he was like a normal kid right
the problem with leaning into crazy guy
is the good thing is you can do anything
and people go oh he's an artist
you know what i mean like johnny depp
can just be a [ __ ] weirdo and people
are like oh no that's so johnny depp
and i think oftentimes people who have
like a lot of social anxiety lean into
this i'm a weirdo character
because it allows them to get away with
all these socially awkward moments right
yeah the problem with leaning into
weirdo guy
is when you get accused of some wild
[ __ ]
mad believable everybody believes in
that like
no question he also he came out with a
movie
like about his childhood where he played
his own dad
honey badger honey boy honey bunny honey
boy honey boy
honey boy and his dad was like
also really abusive like took all of his
money kept him in like a [ __ ] motel
while he's filming a disney show like he
he went through a shitty childhood and
then
the whole point of the movie is like
he's he's there he's
therapy in his way out of it and then
you see these interviews and you're like
oh man this guy really grew up and then
you read this article it's like yo this
guy's been
crazier than ever i don't really hate
this you roll your eyes but i will say i
think on the average a disney channel
kid has a worse life than like
an average american kid no no way
no why first of all if you're on tv and
you're a kid
you never experience like being
uncomfortable with girls
if you were a famous kid you never go
through do girls like me do they not
blah blah blah like you're gonna be
popular with chicks the second that show
comes out through
your 20s i remember when i was in
college there was a [ __ ] what
was that kid's name
johnny tsunami johnny tsunami yellow
colleges
they just was talking about johnny
tsunami
did you meet johnny tell me bro he was
talking about johnny
oh my god i saw johnny tsunami at the
frat party last night johnny tsunami was
there
johnny tsunami johnny tsunami
was hey
how do you get the name though say what
how do you get the name cuz you had
[ __ ] on that
what no the movie that he did for
disney's channel was called johnny
tsunami
his name is brandon i think but he just
bro i don't know but
these girls was going for it yeah you
can really tell andrew's priorities in
life because i was like oh these digital
stars like
they lose their money they get sexually
abused and he's like yeah but they
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] were rejected sorry akka's whole
personality is built off not getting
that [ __ ] in high school
i think that he would have been way
better guy if he was the on to johnny
mudslide
i'm just saying like people
underestimate
one you don't have any financial
problems with your family his dad took
all his money
that's your dad blew that [ __ ] on do
that [ __ ] on
alcohol or drugs or whatever we don't
know what he blew it on bro
we don't know that he didn't blow enough
of it where you were homeless
you had a home you had a motel yeah it
was a roof
yeah you weren't stray you weren't
straight bro and also motel you're an
actor you're staying in hotels all the
time cry baby
i wish i wish you could show people the
apartment where you grew up
my [ __ ] was [ __ ] i mean it is [ __ ]
crazy
fine if i told you who lived in that
building you'd be like get the [ __ ] out
oh yo buddy but also they lived there
after your boy we was there first
there was a basketball court in the
middle of the place yep we had a
basketball court but say where was
but say like what the the story of this
place was
this was my parents
it doesn't even move him i thought the
video paused for me
it was my parents old business that made
so much money they moved to a better
location
and then instead of selling this we were
like let's just live in it exactly tell
your parents to work harder like
my parents care about me and they want
us to have food and a basketball better
childhood than shia labeouf
i don't know we don't know that some of
us was working for [ __ ] at a young age
okay they call him the honey badger what
is the name of it honey boy the honey
boy
[ __ ] was sticking to him money badgers
so funny
free safety for the arizona cardinals
free safety
bro all i'm trying to say is you know
what i mean
you could then live in andrews like post
college apartment and then when it goes
into three apartments yo you had to walk
through the the lion the witch and the
wardrobe
to go through it and you had to go
through a closet and then you could then
end up in his parents place and we're
like
andrew we are 25 years old now son
this is what happens when you deserve
everything you get
here you being like you had a room
bro my [ __ ] was no different than a
motel it was
no different than a motel okay it was
what it was
my parents worked hard you know what i
mean they put everything they ever
gained in their entire lives into a
business selling dance
lessons yeah yeah yeah salsa swing no
nobody's disrespecting
nobody nobody inherited any money well
maybe a little for the down payment of
the place
but i was saying it was salsa it was
morenke it was dango
hard work i never disrespect your
parents
but i'm saying you had a pretty good
childhood relative
son just cuz you had to work a little
bit you know how you didn't have to work
for [ __ ]
tell a girl your address ain't no more
working for [ __ ] hey you know what you
caught it right now all right
my address was sick yo you see the
artwork what you just take ten steps
from there
the hotel location was that shyala booth
was in
also the hotel whatever it was
holiday inn
we singing chingy what are we doing out
here bro the point is
you don't know what his life was like
he's just playing victim bro
exactly now he's just victiming it up
that guy could have way better life than
me the guy's making tons of money making
disney movies all the time my parents
were selling meringues
the only gays you could sell
i'm just saying come on guys
come on guys come on everybody you could
be playing out being a victim now say
what
i think he's being a victim that being
said my life was better than him
[Laughter]
i mean if we getting competitive mr la
boo my life was definitely better you
know
my parents were definitely you said that
with the same level of like certainty
that you earlier said
he had a better childhood than all of us
same level of confidence
position my man didn't have to do no
homework son
think about when you're a kid when
you're a kid you don't know about bills
you know about responsibilities you just
know about homework
you don't gotta do no homework that's a
better childhood
none how stressful that [ __ ] was you
didn't do your homework you on the way
to school trying to do it on the subway
person next you bumping your elbow while
you trying to fill out your [ __ ]
you know algebras you know that [ __ ] is
stressful
he didn't have none of that stress no
none of it the guy's life was way better
than mine even though it wasn't
because mine was better than his because
he didn't fully appreciate how his was
better than mine
bro your idea of what a kid wants in his
life is just like a [ __ ] 90s movie of
like what the kid envisioned
blank check yeah no literally that's
what i was thinking of blank check
exactly and with that blank check what'd
he do homework
go carts go cards oh you're right the
guy could probably do gold cards all the
time you know what he couldn't do with
that blank check
buy your apartment that's a fact that's
a fact
that's a fact you couldn't you got to
get richer so you could afford that
place
sorry posing you know the sad [ __ ] is
huh
i was thinking i was like man maybe i
should just buy my parents [ __ ]
i was my parents should just let them
live in it
you know what i mean and have tons of
money
so they could just do whatever they want
for the rest of their life yeah that's
sweet
and um that's a good idea yeah but
that's just mad expensive
yeah i'm going to say a florida condo
and then get a reverse mortgage mom
figure your [ __ ] out you know
you'd be thinking you could pay off your
parents [ __ ] and then you you look at
the finances you're like how about you
just give me the phone bill and i think
oh you know it's crazy though
they paid those off you know it is what
it is
guys suck it shia there it is you can't
pay off a motel
you [ __ ] we can say it about a guy
who hits women
that's what we should call guys who hit
women yo
that's facts yeah i'm not going to say
you're not gonna you gotta until
after thursday then your boy
is gonna release one in all capitals
come 2021 your boy's back some merengues
flying around
we gotta call him merengues from now on
dude
okay i'm just saying we can't we can't
start feeling bad for these child stars
they didn't have no homework
and they had go craft services also
go-karts but think about craft services
what was the most important [ __ ] nah nah
nah what was the most important [ __ ]
no no i think now i'm getting on your
level right now what was my
lunch what was the most poor [ __ ] at
lunch oh you're really trying to appeal
to a former faculty
that's what i'm saying at lunch you come
through what was your snacks at lunch
what was your snacks desserts what type
of desserts
you had brownies you had you have
brownies you have pudding
i ain't i know pudding but you don't
have any produce in my [ __ ] yep what is
that
cosmic brownie cosmic brown this is
little brownies with the little little
debbie snack cake that white bitch's eye
with me with me too oh the swiss
the swiss rolls bro come on now a honey
bun or two
is that the movie he was one that's the
jameel hipper desserts
could not walk by this one bodega or any
bodega for that matter without going in
and getting a goddamn honey bun he's
addicted
point is at craft services we didn't
have to do that we had maybe one snack
that we could go to school with and then
we would try to flip and flop and try to
hustle
try to you know do what we could do to
get a good snack from the lunchroom
trades
i remember [ __ ] came with an
apple once
idiot trying to trade apple for some
some
snack from sour belts for an apple one
bro
come on bro paper bag sour belts
just like
all i'm saying is that was a
huge source of anxiety for a child
you had to hustle you had to hustle and
you were
judged yeah you know what i mean so
he never had to go through that he had
craft services for anybody who's never
been on a movie you probably could have
filled up your walk-in closet with a lot
of dessert though let me see if i had a
walk-in closet
i did i had my own walk-in closet and
i'd be walking in that [ __ ] bro i'll be
honest with you [ __ ] walk in yo
i this is how much walking you you could
lay in that [ __ ] hey bro jamil smashed
a friend of mine on that walk-in closet
once
i mean that's what we do over here baby
my parents loved me it's that simple one
thing shia had never mentioned is how
fun it is to live in a motel
tell us why you never seen sweet life of
zack and cody no i haven't well you get
to roll around on the bell hop carts for
fun
now they don't have bellhop carts for
motels man i've never been in a
motorcycle i know you have my parents
love me i don't know
hey you sound like a real [ __ ] right
now honestly
it's just shocking to me that we could
feel bad for it
everything can we name any other
problems as a kid they have a problem as
a kid
your parents fighting was his mom around
nope no
problem solved
that's a good ass point problem solved
that's a good ass point you got there
think about it going to bed at any hour
you want
you have a bedtime as a kid do you not i
did
that [ __ ] was a little restrictive it
was restrictive
mm-hmm i felt confined by my bedtime
okay do you think shaw had a bad time
hey nine nine thirty that [ __ ]
getting ready for leno
you know what you are damn right about
that he might stay up for conan he might
stay up
something i hate is i got a tv privilege
turned off at a certain time
was that at birth yep because mark
hasn't seen any movies in his entire
life
yeah that's a wild thing before yeah but
i've watched all even steven so you
don't even know who shai labou is
outside of even
well he knows tv he does know tv what
time was tv off
i was like 10 o'clock 10 o'clock ah
that's reasonable hours
go sky labouf got to make tv childbirth
got to make tv and he got to be
literally he was probably up until 12
o'clock sometimes
as a kid midnight he saw midnight he saw
midnight no kids on midnight
no kids bullied him right he had
security he had
security oh wow he had security no
bullets
no bullies also he's a child star so
that means he's only around
other child stars you think they pick
the ugly ass little kids to be child
stars
you back to [ __ ] right now yeah yeah
okay let's go
there was that one kid from even
stephen's beans remember that kid okay
no
he was [ __ ] yo that little kid was
[ __ ] straight up that's why he
called him beans and i thought that was
hard
look how beans even see he was his child
even stevens that was so [ __ ] so
weird-looking me and my eyes tell me
ain't [ __ ]
they called him beans that was wildly
offensive okay yeah he might be a little
bit
he's yeah he's vaccine ninja for sure
but he
oh we got to get that vaccine by the way
he was a weirdo oh [ __ ]
and then he grew up and now he just
still looks just like him but weird
weird the grinch yeah go to the top
right one where his bald on the top
so that's your point do i ever have ugly
child actors the answer is
yes yeah that's a wild boy right man got
extra chromosomes for sure
beans from even stevens works as a
santa's helper at the mall
yeah that's disrespectful when they like
you can't have a regular job after being
a child actor
you've
you [ __ ] your whole argument with that
[Applause]
one
you